[Music]
today's episode is brought to you by
resident evil to experience the thrills
of the survival horror classic rebuild
from the ground up after nine sequels
and reboots that range from Matt to
please kill man only one creative team
can restore the Halloween franchise to
its former glory
Kenny Powers and the director of your
highness
Halloween 2018 get ready for a snazzed
up reboot of the original or rather a
reboot of the original sequel or maybe a
new take on h2o I don't know man but
this time there's even more carnage for
jump scares and even more those stupid
fake out jump scares that end up being
something else
we just stop with that it's like a
comedy stick with you to get a laugh
it's cheating
you want to change don't you guys return
to the world of Halloween where the
doctors are still shady the cops are
still useless what am i gon do chá
swallowing and Haddonfield hasn't
changed at all except for recent boom in
Asian food offerings
Avani sandwich bonnie is essentially
just the Vietnamese version of a French
baguette thrill as we reunite with
Laurie Strode once they literally prior
to be in the movie how does $3,000 sound
she's still haunted by that night 40
years ago so she became Sarah Connor a
hardcore survivalist convinced a final
showdown is coming with an estranged
child she trained to fight but while
some families bond over brunch and spa
days Lori will bring her clan together
the old-fashioned way by turning the
tables on their relentless stalker in a
finale that will be be wondering okay
she had 40 years to design a trap house
and this is the best she could do a
shotgun and a roomful of mannequins and
in a second Oh No
why are they anatomically correct is it
really is the team that made your
highness
yeah audiences will need Activia to crap
their pants because Michael Myers is bad
because you can run you can hide but
actually you could he's not much of a
mover now say goodbye to the slasher you
thought you whoo because Michael is 40
years older and he's matured into more
of a Shover
hey I get it man
get your sixties and you got to conserve
that energy but get ready to meet the
real monsters in town
true crime podcasters watch these twits
open the film by recording what would
have been a terrible series complete
with tons of background noise having
witnessed the animal and its captive
stays this monster not calling ahead to
secure their biggest interview we're
making a podcast pointing their mics at
the subjects back from 20 yards away in
the wind alarm icon and recording their
podcast on the 40 year anniversary of
the murders instead of releasing it then
come on hello anybody ever heard of SEO
just awful the true crime podcast about
the murder of the true crime podcasters
though now that's a season of serial so
suit up for a progressive horror film
about women fighting back against the
men who traumatized them with the
undercurrent that people with mental
illness are scary and violent and should
be killed or locked away forever but
it's easily the second best film in the
franchise just by doing what the first
movie did again what Samuels is really
talking about here is fate fate took a
different course
[Music]
[Applause]
while sometimes doing things the first
movie did in Reverse
[Music]
dude what if in the next one they switch
it up and have Michael Mars hon Laurie
whoa wait
starring Clint Eastwood okay Michael say
goodbye to these your next sassy
magazine sassiest sassy boy obligatory
horror movie stoner sir
dr. new Miss marks Karen and scare Akane
egg or you must dismember this how did
this get slayed how about two dopes
screams this American knife okay okay
one more wait wait don't kill me stab of
my haters and this line for some reason
I got peanut butter on my penis
Halloween - okay so when they make a
sequel to this movie are they going to
call that movie Halloween - because this
movie is a sequel to the original
replacing the original Halloween - so
the next Halloween - would actually be
Halloween 3 and my nose is bleeding
this episode was brought to you by
Resident Evil 2 available on PlayStation
4 Xbox one and Steve I hear the call of
the void and I must answer her I'm a
pretty unicorn admire me and Stroke my
Mane while I stab you with my horn